y saben lo que creía aristóteles
aristóteles decía que pensamos con el
corazón y que el cerebro solo se dedica
a enfriar la sangre que viene caliente
del corazón después de haber pensado
no les parece una barbaridad que una de
las mentes más brillantes de la historia
de la humanidad haya equiparado al
cerebro humano con un radiador
creo que todos estamos de acuerdo en que
aristóteles esta vez estaba equivocado
hace más o menos 10 años se investigó la
relación entre el corazón y el cerebro
básicamente la forma en que el corazón
produce enfermedades neurológicas como
los accidentes cerebrovasculares o
aceves y como el cerebro produce
enfermedades cardiológicas como las
arritmias
y en este camino de la investigación me
llevé un montón de sorpresas eso de que
pensamos exclusivamente con el cerebro y
que el corazón solo bombea sangre no es
tan así
por ejemplo cuántas veces les dijeron
que le sigan con el corazón
qué tiene que ver esta bomba de puro
músculo con tomar una decisión o tal vez
con las intuiciones qué es lo que
necesitamos para tomar decisiones a
veces
hay un estudio de la universidad de
cambridge que revolucionó el tema de
decidir con el corazón y abre un camino
enorme en lo que nosotros llamamos
investigación sobre toma de decisiones
en este estudio se le pidió a algunas
personas que participen de un juego en
el cual tenían que tomar decisiones
basadas en situaciones simuladas en una
computadora
y siempre había dos opciones entre las
cuales tenían que decidir una de ellas
iba a tener un resultado positivo o
favorable y la otra iba a tener un
resultado desfavorable y mientras
participaban del juego se les
monitoreaban los latidos cardíacos para
saber cómo reaccionaba el corazón justo
antes de tomar una decisión
y lo que encontraron los investigadores
fue que antes de tomar una decisión que
iba a tener un resultado favorable el
corazón latirá de una forma específica
pero cuando iban a tomar una decisión
que iba a tener un resultado negativo la
tiene una forma totalmente distinta es
decir que aparentemente el corazón sabía
antes de que el cerebro fuera consciente
si la decisión que se estaba por tomar
iba a tener un resultado favorable o
desfavorable
o les pido que se les pido que se
guarden esto en la cabeza y vamos a
hacer un ejercicio nosotros vamos a
experimentar con nuestro cuerpo les voy
a pedir que cierren todos los ojos
todos cierran los ojos mantengamos
silencio y pongan sus manos sobre las
rodillas hasta que yo les diga
y mientras hacemos esta prueba
quiero que traten de ver si pueden
sentir sus latidos cardíacos
muy bien ahora vamos por favor los ojos
y ahora les voy a pedir que levanten la
mano quienes hayan podido sentir sus
latidos
perfecto más o menos el 50% entre las
personas que levantaron las manos
probablemente hacia muchos que tienen
desarrollada una capacidad que se llama
intercepción
es la intercepción simplemente la
capacidad de sentir los mensajes que nos
da nuestro cuerpo que nos envía a
nuestro cuerpo como por ejemplo en este
caso los latidos cardíacos
volviendo al experimento de la
universidad de cambridge las personas
que estaban participando del juego
habían hecho exactamente lo mismo que
ustedes y habían sido clasificadas en
quienes tenían buena intercepción o mala
intercepción
y lo más interesante de este experimento
es que quienes tenían buena intercepción
tomaron decisiones favorables mucho más
frecuentemente que quienes no tenían
buena intercepción
la conclusión de este experimento parece
ser que quienes tienen la capacidad
de detectar decodificar y procesar los
mensajes que nos mandan a nuestro
corazón antes de decidir aparentemente
podrían tomar mejores decisiones por
supuesto que con todo experimento
revolucionario como éste es necesario
confirmarlo con otros científicos que
hagan la misma prueba pero mientras
tanto no les parece que no están tan mal
algunas frases como escucha tu corazón
o tengo una corazonada al momento de
decidir
pero como hacen el corazón y el cerebro
para interactuar de esta manera al
momento de tomar una decisión hay un
área específica dentro del cerebro que
es el foco de nuestras investigaciones
que se llama ínsula se llama ínsula
porque es como una isla que está debajo
de la corteza cerebral oculta y que está
híper conectada con todo el cerebro es
como si fuera el gran aeropuerto local a
dónde llegan y de dónde se van todas las
conexiones pero la ínsula también está
conectada con otros órganos como el
corazón y el intestino entre otros y por
lo tanto también es el gran aeropuerto
internacional a dónde llegan y desde
dónde se van todas las conexiones que
están fuera del cerebro
y lo que tiene de interesante la ínsula
es que es pura neurona y el corazón es
puro músculo entonces ustedes me pueden
decir cómo hacen para comunicarse estos
dos órganos tan distintos
la respuesta es bastante sorprendente
porque el corazón así como el cerebro
tiene neuronas
esos puntos blancos que ustedes ven en
el corazón son neuronas grupos de
neuronas a donde llegan las conexiones
que vienen del cerebro
y eso que ustedes están viendo es un
típico corazón es la anatomía de un
corazón y qué pasó a lo largo de la
humanidad para que un corazón como ese
se transforme en el símbolo universal
del amor qué tiene que ver el corazón
con amar o enamorarse
en otro experimento le pidieron a
algunas personas que traigan fotos de
alguien a quien amaban profundamente y
de alguien que les era totalmente
indiferente y les hicieron una
resonancia magnética especial que se
llama funcional que nos permite ver qué
áreas del cerebro se están activando
ante determinados estímulos o
determinadas acciones
y lo que se vio en este experimento es
que cuando las personas veían la foto de
la persona a quien amaban se iluminaban
áreas relacionadas con el placer y con
la recompensa
y no casualmente una de esas áreas era
la ínsula
la ínsula parece estar involucrada en
algunas funciones junto con otras áreas
del cerebro que nos permiten darnos
cuenta que estamos enamorados de una
persona nos permite decir esa es la
persona de la cual yo estoy enamorado y
aparte por sus conexiones con el cerebro
con sus cuerpos sus conexiones con el
corazón y con el intestino hace que
cuando estamos con esa persona a quien
amamos tengamos taquicardia
palpitaciones y esa sensación de
mariposas que a veces se describe en el
estómago cuando estamos enamorados
entonces señores nos enamoramos con el
cerebro y no con el corazón
y este grado de interconexión
hay entre el cerebro y que tenemos
también con la ínsula hace que tenga
repercusiones funcionales pero que
también haya repercusiones que
que pueden resultar en problemas de
salud
por ejemplo
les quiero mostrar en este gráfico acá
tienen en el eje horizontal los meses de
mayo junio y julio y en el eje vertical
tienen la cantidad de infartos cardíacos
que hubo en la ciudad de munich
en el año 2000
en el año 2003 la cantidad de infartos
en esos tres meses se mantuvo constante
no hubo cambios año 2005 pasó algo
similar
el año 2006 mayo sigue todo igual
junio y julio explota el número de
infartos en múnich que pasó
muy bien muchos de ustedes ya se dieron
cuenta y es el mundial de fútbol 2006
y cada partido que jugó alemania es uno
de los picos que ustedes están viendo en
la diapositiva
y más interesante todavía es que el pico
número 5 es el partido por cuartos de
final que jugó alemania con argentina
y que prefiero no decir cómo terminó
ese partido lo estaba viendo un amigo
que se llama hands en su casa
france estaba sentado frente al
televisor y se pasó viendo el primero y
el segundo tiempo que terminaron
empatados y toda la definición por
penales estaba ganando alemania 4 a 2
faltaba el último penal
cambiasso se prepara para patear y stan
lehman en el arco de alemania
patea cambiasso ataja alemán clasifica
alemania y hans
que es el equivalente alemán del tano
pasman
pega el grito de su vida libera toda la
energía y toda la adrenalina que acumuló
durante esos 90 minutos más los penales
y en cuanto terminó de gritar a la
tajada del penal fue a parar directo al
hospital con un infarto
como muchos otros alemanes ese día en
que se triplicaron el número de infartos
en la ciudad
hans es un ejemplo viviente de cómo
algunas emociones que afectan nuestro
cerebro hacen que en forma transitiva
terminemos teniendo un problema cardíaco
el estrés que tuvo hands esa sobredosis
de adrenalina terminó comprometiendo el
corazón y produciendo el infarto
entonces uno acá se plantea
tenemos que resignarnos y aceptar que
estamos expuestos a lo que este sistema
tan complejo corazón cerebro no se
expone en cuanto a nuestras emociones o
hay algo que podamos hacer
la ciencia nos está abriendo muchas
puertas una de ellas esas técnicas
milenarias
técnicas que por más que tenga miles y
miles de años solo sean investigados
seria intensivamente en los últimos años
y una de ellas es el mindfulness
el mindfulness es una especie de técnica
de meditación que no
que nos permite concentrarnos en todo lo
que está pasando alrededor
en las sensaciones en las emociones
y en los mensajes de nuestro cuerpo les
suena esto de mensajes de nuestro cuerpo
intercepción
cuando me hablan de mindfulness hace
unos 10 o 12 años será absolutamente
incrédulo porque por supuesto no había
ninguna evidencia científica nada y como
penn solemos pensar con una mente médica
y científica cualquier cosa que no se ha
aprobado no sirve entonces miren lo que
pasó en los últimos 10 años 2005 a 2015
publicaciones científicas que en el
título tiene la palabra mindfulness
aumentaron enormemente y gran parte de
ellas la parte más importante de todas
estas publicaciones que están viendo
está relacionada con la utilidad del
mindfulness para combatir cosas como el
estrés yo sé que ustedes son escépticos
que tienen una mente curiosa y que no se
van a creer cualquier cosa que les esté
diciendo entonces vamos a jugar que
ustedes son los científicos y les pido
que piensen qué situación estresante
podríamos usar para comprobar si el
mindfulness es útil o no es útil para
combatir el estrés pues la peor de las
situaciones
la guerra
en california hay un centro donde los
marines son entrenados antes de ser
enviados al campo de batalla es el
último entrenamiento donde se hace un
simulacro super estresante en el cual
los marines están enfrentados a soldados
que tienen la fisonomía de quienes van a
enfrentar los ruidos son los mismos los
olores son los mismos
y descripto por ellos mismos es el
momento más estresante antes de ir a la
guerra
en este centro de entrenamiento se tomó
la mitad de los marines y se les ofreció
ser mindfulness ocho semanas y el resto
la vida de siempre
hicieron el mindfulness se sometieron al
simulacro este terrible
y después del simulacro se les hizo un
cuestionario en el cual se les pregunta
cuán estresados estaban y lo interesante
es que quienes habían hecho mindfulness
estaban mucho menos estresados que
quienes no habían hecho este es me
pueden decir claro esto es su gestión
porque como hicieron mindfulness van a
decir que tienen menos estrés pero
también se les midió en sangre una
proteína que libera el cerebro ante
situaciones de extremado o de extremo
estrés y los marines que habían hecho
mindfulness tenían niveles muchísimo más
bajos que quienes no lo habían hecho o
sea que hay una demostración subjetiva y
objetiva de que algo podemos hacer para
disminuir el estrés y como este hay
muchos otros experimentos que son los
que muestran este gráfico entonces
pareciera que gracias a cosas que
existen hace mucho tiempo y que la
ciencia está mostrando ahora tal vez
tengamos la posibilidad de disminuir el
impacto de algunas emociones sobre
nuestra salud y sobre el sistema corazón
cerebro y tal vez en el futuro esto lo
diría la ciencia hasta se puedan
prevenir enfermedades como la acb o
infartos cardíacos usando este tipo de
técnicas por ahora creo que todos
tenemos que
reconocer el genio de aristóteles que
fue el primero en pensar que el corazón
y el cerebro funcionan como sistema
y creo que también es bueno recordar las
palabras de un gran sabio que dijo que
un buen corazón y un buen cerebro son
una combinación formidable muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]